offener machtkampf um die cdu-spitze
armin laschet friedrich merz und norbert
röttgen wollen jetzt alle offiziell
parteichef werden entsetzen trauer und
viele fragen warum rast ein mann in die
menge beim rosenmontagsumzug und
verletzt in volkmarsen in hessen fast 60
menschen quarantäne für ein ganzes hotel
auf teneriffa sitzen hunderte touristen
fest weil sich zwei gäste wohl mit dem
corona virus infiziert haben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und in allen an diesem
dienstag zum nachrichtenüberblick heute
um 7 sport nachher in der sendung mit
norbert könig ja genannt
der machtkampf um die cdu spitze ist
jetzt voll entbrannt und klar ist damit
auch es wird eine kampfabstimmung geben
auf dem sonderparteitag am 25 april
zwischen doch sehr unterschiedlichen
konzepten und kandidaten die karten
liegen also auf dem tisch vergangene
woche hatte sich norbert röttgen als
erster aus der deckung gewagt und seine
kandidatur offiziell verkündet
auftrumpfen will er mit einer frau an
seiner seite
wer das sein soll ist noch nicht bekannt
nrw-ministerpräsident armin laschet
zieht heute nach mit
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn im
team
ihm soll der vize chef posten winken
wenn laschet gewinnt und auch der
ehemalige fraktionschef friedrich merz
ist seit heute offiziell mit dabei auch
er will parteichef werden über den
cdu-kandidaten poker berichtet winnie
heescher
mit diesem auftritt wird offenbar der
einzelnen kämpfen will und wer nicht der
gesundheitsminister jens spahn will
nicht parteiisch sparen werden
er war beim letzten mal im wettkampf um
den parteivorsitz unterlegen jetzt sei
die cdu in der größten krise ihrer
geschichte
da braucht es team reist in alle ihre
persönlichen ambitionen absolut stellen
ist zusammenarbeit und zusammenhalt
schwierig ich werde daher nicht für den
vorsitz der cdu kandidieren stattdessen
unterstütze ich angelastet armin laschet
gibt mit einem amtsbonus ins rennen er
ist ministerpräsident von nrw parteivize
und grenzt sich hier schnell klar von
friedrich merz ab er hat immer sehr
stark gesagt er will die afg halbieren
das ist natürlich ein wünschenswertes
ziel in nordrhein westfalen haben wir
sie schwach gehalten sie war bei der
landtagswahl und in allen umfragen bei 7
prozent und man sollte sie unter 5
bringen
aber der wettbewerb findet auch in die
mitte hinein stadt hinein in die
pressekonferenz twittert mitbewerber
röcken in meinem team wird eine frau
sein
das team laschet will nicht sagen warum
es nicht gelungen ist freut kann und
märz einzubinden will letztlich über
norbert röttgen spricht friedrich merz
hat
klar sei bisher dass ich ihn schätze
seine stärken und wie weit er sich
danach in die partei und in einen
wahlkampf einbringt das muss man mit ihm
besprechen
dass das dem mitte man laschet und dem
konservativeren sparen in diesem
wettbewerb nicht gelingen wird wird
schnell klar
friedrich merz kommt exakt 30 sekunden
nach den konkurrenten und macht deutlich
dass er seinen weg allein machen will
ich spiele hier nicht auf platz sondern
auf sieg und deswegen beschäftige ich
mich mit der frage auch ernst
hoffentlich ich will gewinnen
seine strategie er will aus der wahl
eine richtungsentscheidung über den
weiteren kurs der cdu machen wir haben
ab heute die alternative zwischen
kontinuität und aufbruch und erneuerung
ich stehe für aufbruch und erneuerung
der cdu
die kandidaten werden sich nun beweisen
müssen alle aus
wie alle über 50 katholisch und mit
ambitionen fürs kanzleramt zuerst aber
muss es mit dem parteichef klappen so
sieht's aus kommt man auch mal kurz auf
den zeitplan mit theo koll in berlin
theo genannt werden wir jetzt heftigen
wahlkampf erleben bis ende april in der
cdu naja ich glaube davon dürfen wir
getrost ausgehen dass stehen jetzt nicht
nur kampferprobte politischer alpha
männer im ring es geht auch natürlich um
die große frage wie die zeit nach der
märke lehrer aussehen soll und die
analyse warum ist der cdu aktuell so
schlecht geht und wie das zu heilen
seien könnte die ist natürlich sehr
unterschiedlich und daher unterscheiden
sich auch die richtungs empfehlung für
die zukunft jens spahn meinte heute die
cdu befindet sich in der größten krise
ihrer geschichte entsprechend hart
dürfte da auch der kampf um köpfe und um
die künftige richtung auch in den
nächsten wochen werden gäbe es
vielleicht einmal kurz durch wer spielt
jetzt mit höchstem risiko und wer mit
größten erfolgsaussichten
also ich glaube das dürfte jeweils armin
laschet sein er spielt mit dem höchsten
risiko denn sollte er nicht als sieger
aus dem wettbewerb hervor gehen dann
wäre er in nordrhein-westfalen
angeschlagen für die ministerpräsidenten
in nordrhein westfalen und bayern galt
ja in der politik schon immer sie müssen
kanzler fähig sein und wenn er schon am
parteivorsitz scheitern würde wäre er
schwer beschädigt aber laschet hat auch
die größten erfolgsaussichten denn das
doppel laschet sparen deckt zusammen
eine große programmatische bandbreite ab
sparen wird einen teil des konservativen
lagers binden laschet die merkel jana
märz hat es heute als kartellbildung
kritisierte die solisten dürften ist
dagegen schwer haben
theo herzlichen dank armin laschet ist
das stichwort mehr zu dem thema gleich
nach unserer sendung hin was nun herr
laschet fragen von bettina schausten und
peter frey und einer zusammenfassung
wofür laschet märz und roetgen stehen
auf heute.de zum nachlesen und dann
heute die situation in dem kleinen
nordhessischen ort volkmarsen am tag
nachdem ein 29-jähriger dort mit dem
auto in zuschauer des rosenmontagszuges
fuhr
das motiv des fahrers ist noch immer
völlig unklar dem mann wird versuchter
tötung vorgeworfen er soll heute noch
dem haftrichter vorgeführt werden
die zahl der verletzten ist mittlerweile
auf fast 60 gestiegen darunter viele
kinder
mehr als 30 verletzte müssen noch immer
im krankenhaus behandelt werden
die menschen in volkmarsen versuchen
heute abend bei einem ökumenischen
gottesdienst trost zu finden peterwagen
ökumenische gottesdienst für angehörige
opfer und helfer ganz volkmarsen steht
und bietet gemeinsam am abend nach der
schreckenstat mit fast 60 verletzten
ich glaube der dürfte sechs
rettungswagen mit vor ort und auch
direkt mit draußen haben angefangen zu
helfen wo es nur ging was auch sehr
schwer war am anfang erst von überblick
zu behalten heute bin ich einfach hier
und mitgefühl eben wie gesagt auch mit
auszudrucken
gestern gegen 14.30 steuert ein
29-jähriger deutscher seinen mercedes
kombi wohl mit absicht in die zuschauer
des karnevalszuges entsetzen panik
allein 18 kinder sind unter den opfern
jeder hilft sofort wo er kann
der schrecken kommt dann hinterher wenn
man alleine ist und wenn man zur eigenen
familie wiederkommt und weiß dass die
familie nicht betroffen ist unsere
kinder sind auch im karneval man zum
glück nicht an dieser stelle
und ja darüber kommt zu einem dann
natürlich emotional
der fahrer war entgegen ersten meldungen
nicht alkoholisiert ob drogen im spiel
waren wird noch geprüft
der 29 jährige wohnt in volkmarsen ist
zuvor wegen nötigung und beleidigung bei
der polizei aufgefallen
zu motiv bisher keine neuen erkenntnisse
es gab eine zweite festnahme
ein passant hatte in rücksichtsloser
weise die opfer gefilmt der zweite
festgenommene gegen den läuft zurzeit
ein ermittlungsverfahren wegen
verletzung des höchstpersönlichen
lebensbereiches durch bildaufnahmen
besser bekannt unter dem synonym gaffer
video das ist eine straftat die mit bis
zu zwei jahren strafandrohung belegt ist
gott sieht unseren schmerz eine gemeinde
im gebiet vereint für die vielen opfer
aus ihrer mitte und alle stellen sich
die frage nach dem motiv der
schreckenstat elisabeth schmidt ist für
uns live in volkmarsen elisabeth heute
abend ein gottesdienst für den ganzen
ort wie versucht volkmarsen denn jetzt
mit diesem furchtbaren geschehen
umzugehen
der gottesdienst ist es gerade vor fünf
minuten zu ende gegangen und hinter mir
sieht man immer noch es stehen ganz
viele menschen noch in kleinen grüppchen
zusammen
sie haben wirklich redebedarf viele
haben sich während des gottesdienstes an
den händen gefasst in die arme genommen
einige haben kerzen mitgebracht einige
haben auch karnevalskostüme noch an
gehabt hier soll wirklich ein zeichen
gesetzt werden wir sind mehr wir stehen
zusammen in volkmarsen
ich habe mit einigen betroffenen
gesprochen einem ersthelfer der ganz als
erstes zum unfall gekommen ist zum
schrecklichen anschlag er hat mir
erzählt wie furchtbar es für ihn war wie
sehr ihn das belastet und wie viel es
ihm auch gibt heute mit vielen im gebiet
und auch in den fürbitten
zusammenzustehen
es gab auch einige die erzielt haben sie
sind vorletzten jahr waren sie auch
schon an diesem karnevalsumzug oder
wollten dorthin standen fast an
derselben stelle und sind einfach immer
noch schockiert und fassungslos was dort
passiert ist
viele sagen dass wichtige heute an
diesem tag ist zu zeigen wir sind mehr
und wir wollen uns von einem einzeltäter
auch die freude an dem karneval in
zukunft nicht verderben lassen sagte
diese witsch mit live in volkmarsen
herzlichen dank elisabeth und jetzt in
dieser sendung heute abend zu dem thema
dessen enorme tragweite sich fast
stündlich klarer abzeichnet corona virus
in europa immer mehr länder melden
bestätigte fälle
österreich die schweiz kroatien vor
allem aber italien mehr als 320
infizierte und schon elf tote gibt es
dort inzwischen wie man das virus in
seiner ausbreitung überhaupt noch
stoppen kann oder wenigstens bremsen
darüber berieten heute
eu-gesundheitsminister in rom
konkret geht es um maßnahmen bis hin zu
grenzkontrollen andreas postel berichtet
am bahnhof der norditalienischen
metropole mailand sind die
atemschutzmasken ausverkauft es ist
etwas weniger betrieb als sonst am
bahnsteig die passanten haben gemischte
gefühle im gepäck es geht ein bisschen
die angst um wir sind aus rom jetzt hier
ferien zu machen verunsichert und die
rote zone die abgesperrten ortschaften
in der lombardei sind nur 60 kilometer
entfernt hier im krankenhaus in córdoba
nahm die verbreitung ihren lauf zu spät
war bei einem 38-jährigen die infektion
diagnostiziert worden
die beiden hotspots in der lombardei und
venetien bleiben bis auf weiteres
abgeriegelt die italienische regierung
zeigt stärke um nicht schwach zu wirken
aus südtirol der emiglia romana und auf
sizilien wurden vereinzelt neue
infizierte gemeldet
die auswirkungen auf wirtschaft und
tourismus in italien schon jetzt spürbar
premierminister konnte versucht zu
beruhigen
italien ist ein sicheres land ein land
in das man reisen kann auch als tourist
es gibt einige wenige zonen unseres
staatsgebietes die begrenzt zugänglich
sind aber im rest des gesamten landes
kann man beruhigt reisen
am abend treffen der gesundheitsminister
in rom
es gibt lob für die massnahmen italiens
und gemeinsame verabredungen für das
weitere vorgehen
wir sind gemeinsam der meinung dass zu
diesem zeitpunkt jetzt
reisebeschränkungen oder gar das
schließen von grenzen keine angemessene
verhältnismäßige maßnahme wäre dass es
angemessen ist im einzelfall zu
entscheiden ob auch größere
veranstaltungen stattfinden so hat
italien entschieden fußballspiele in der
serie a im betroffenen norden ohne fans
als geister spiele stattfinden zu lassen
derweil hat das virus auch das spanische
festland erreicht in barcelona wurde
eine frau positiv getestet nachdem sie
aus norditalien zurückgekommen war und
auf teneriffa steht ein ganzes hotel
unter quarantäne bei zwei gästen einem
italienischen arzt und seiner frau wurde
der erreger nachgewiesen und jetzt
sitzen hier rund 1000 urlauber darunter
auch deutsche fest das gebäude ist
abgeriegelt und die hotelgäste dürfen
ihre zimmer nicht mehr verlassen
sie sollen jetzt alle auf das virus
getestet werden man kann sich also
ausmalen was das potenziell bedeuten
kann für den tourismus für den export
heute bereits wieder krisenstimmung an
den börsen frank bethmann in frankfurt
auf welches szenario muss ich denn die
wirtschaft einstellen na ja lange hatte
man ja irgendwie gehofft drum herum zu
kommen ja sicher eine kleine
konjunkturdelle war einkalkuliert aber
mehr dann auch nicht mittlerweile werden
die zweifel daran größer als erstes
reagiert die lufthansa mit drastischen
maßnahmen stellt neubesetzungen von
offenen stellen in frage denn längst
geht es ja nicht - china geschäft auch
das europäische ist inzwischen gefährdet
und das betrifft nicht nur die
fluggesellschaften sondern auch die
autoindustrie die maschinenbauer oder
den luxusgüter bereich alle sind sie ja
abhängig davon dass überall auf der welt
gekauft und investiert wird und auch der
dax bekommt mittlerweile kalte füße von
gestern und heute zusammen fast sechs
prozent sehr treffend formulierte es
vorhin ein marktbeobachter
deutschlands stärkste trumpfkarte der
export hat sich zum schwachpunkt
entwickelt frank vielen dank das virus
seine ausbreitung und die gefahren für
die gesundheit dazu haben wir einen live
stream ab 20 uhr 30 zu sehen in der zdf
mediathek und auf heute.de
hosni mubarak stand länger an der spitze
von ägypten als jeder andere präsident
jetzt ist der ehemalige machthaber im
alter von 91 jahren gestorben fast 30
jahre war mubarak an der macht er
regierte autoritär gegen islamistische
extremisten griff erhard tot
die massenproteste des arabischen
frühlings zwang in 2011 zum rücktritt
wegen des todes hunderter demonstranten
wurde er verurteilt später aber
freigesprochen
die letzten jahre seines lebens
verbrachte er größtenteils in
krankenhäusern karneval in rio das ist
für uns der inbegriff brasilianischer
lebensfreude aber bei der furiosen show
der sambaschulen findet immer öfter auch
der alltag der menschen in den armen
vierteln seinen niederschlag und der
besteht zunehmend aus polizei gewalt
rassismus und hass auf homosexuelle ziel
der kritik im karneval ist brasiliens
rechtsextremer präsident aus rio
berichtet christoph rath
es ist das nicht unumstrittene highlight
des diesjährigen karneval in rio
jesus am kreuz allerdings sei als junger
schwarzer mann aus einer favela einem
armenviertel durchsiebt von kugel
die botschaft der sambaschule magiera
ist klar jesus wäre heute einer von uns
er würde in der favela man gera geboren
wäre schwarz und ganz sicher würde er
von rios polizei getötet
karneval als abrechnung mit der
regierung in ihrem samba singen sie vom
propheten der intoleranz vom messias mit
der waffe in der hand
gemeinsam mit es zweifelsfrei basel
jetzt rechtsextremer präsident von sony
wo er sich immer wieder auf jesus beruf
ein jesus der nicht der ihre ist jesus
satz schwule als indigene als frau als
vertreter aller gruppen die sich von der
regierung wohl zu nahe bedroht fühlt ich
repräsentiere die frauen die auf der
welt angegriffen und ermordet werden
schon im vorfeld hatten konservative
christliche gruppen gegen den umzug
protestiert der präsident selbst hat
sich über die karnevalszeit
zurückgezogen es ist so politisch wie
lange nicht mehr
es geht um korruption rassismus
umweltzerstörung völkermord an den
indigenen
hier können wir sagen was wir wollen es
ist unsere art zu protestieren protest
verpackt wie immer in einem wettbewerb
aus farben formen und ideen die weltweit
ihresgleichen sucht
und damit nur beim sport in der sendung
jetzt einmal durchatmen genau stichwort
ko-duell erster teil im fußball in der
bundesliga erfolgreich und in der
champions league tatendurstig mit einem
starken auftritt in london beim fc
chelsea will der fc bayern münchen den
grundstein legen für das erreichen des
viertelfinales londoner schmuddelwetter
beim abschlusstraining des fc chelsea
ungemütlicher wind im stadion die blues
wollen den bayern einen heißen tanz
liefern so köhler gegangen
es gibt ein hin und ein rückspiel es ist
die ko phase der champions league eins
ist doch klar wir müssen konzentriert
und fokussiert sein auf den punkt
absolut der glanz vergangener tage ein
bisschen verblasst chelsea mit junge
mannschaft und im umbruch die bayern
wittern ihre chance
wir sind in der spur und von daher bin
ich da wirklich voller selbstvertrauen
noch was was die mannschaft angeht dass
sie das gut umsetzt teil eins heute an
der dann voll besetzten stamford bridge
das rückspiel in drei wochen in münchen
emotionaler abschied von einer
basketball legende 20.000 menschen kamen
zur gedenkfeier in los angeles für kobe
bryant und seine tochter gianna die bei
einem hubschrauberabsturz ums leben
gekommen waren zahlreiche prominente aus
showbusiness und sport würdigte den star
der los angeles lakers der bereits
anfang februar mit seiner tochter
beigesetzt worden ist seine witwe
vanessa sagte sie werde die anderen drei
töchter immer daran erinnern was für ein
toller ehemann und vater kobe gewesen
sei auftrag schadensbegrenzung der neue
trainer uwe krupp soll mit den kölner
haien den freien fall in der deutschen
eishockey-liga stoppen
erst ende januar wurde bei sparta prag
entlassen jetzt kehrt der frühere
bundestrainer uwe krupp nach sechs
jahren wieder zu den kölner haien zurück
und soll retten was zu retten ist nach
17 niederlagen in serie war am sonntag
sein vorgänger mike stewart den job los
geworden auf den gebürtigen kölner
gruppe wartet eine undankbare aufgabe
das ist eine mannschaft die im moment
natürlich nicht das selbstbewusstsein
hat was sie die erfolgreichste saison
spielt und das kommt erst dann zurück
wenn du ein bisschen erfolg hast
die playoffs sind für köln nicht mehr zu
erreichen am abend gegen wolfsburg droht
die 18 niederlage nach einer
der negativrekord der liga wäre
eingestellt krupp soll das verhindern
und das was von mir ich habe noch ein
bisschen schnee der kommt nach
deutschland und wo wann und für wen sagt
ihnen gleich katja horneffer ich
empfehle ihnen das heute journal mit den
kollegen claus kleber um 21.50 er hat
fragen an jens spahn zur lage der cd
morgen gibt es wieder punkt 19 uhr vom
gesamten team in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren jetzt will es der
winter tatsächlich nochmal wissen es
drohen kleine weiße überraschungen und
auf straßenglätte heute nacht kann es
also glatt werden vor allen dingen den
mittelgebirgen aber auch sonst denn es
gibt schnee regen und schneeschauer
nur im nordosten bleibt es trocken bei
temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt kommt
der wind meist aus westlichen bis
südwestlichen richtungen dreht morgen
über tag dann aber mehr und mehr auf
nordwest und es gibt weitere kräftige
schnee und schneeregen schauer
es bleibt glatt auf den straßen bei
temperaturen nur wenig über null grad
gewitter gibt es auch und am
freundlichsten wird es ganz im norden am
donnerstag überquert uns ein kleines
schneesturm tief und zum wochenende wird
es milder und regnerischer nahm noch